it's the end of an HGTV era chip and
Joanna Gaines are done with fixer-upper
the season will be our last it's a
bittersweet time for us because the last
five years I mean this has been our life
this show the crew here like these homes
that we've you know gotten a renovate
for these beautiful families it's just
become such a big part of our lives the
couple announced the news to fans in a
vlog on their website on Tuesday adding
in a blog post quote thank you for
sharing life with us and for the
continued support they say they're
walking away to focus on their family
our first priority even before all of
this was our children and our marriage
and so I think literally daily we have
to look at each other and go how are you
doing how are we doing and then how are
the kids and you know we want them to
know they're the most important thing to
us so new episodes of The Home Makeover
show will air well into 2018 welcome huh
and the couple promises they'll continue
to run their businesses in their
hometown of Waco Texas just not on TV so
thank you we can't wait to see what's
next we believe in our hearts think
we're gonna see you again right around
the corner so stay tuned
you
[Music]